PEGI 12
Atlas faithful John Hardin here joining
by none other than Xander mobis hello
we're here to talk about something you
may have heard of it before it's called
persona 5 that ring a bell
no no what it what is what is that I do
not like Irishman ain't I pretty had
kind of a big role in it like Oh for
real yeah I sure does
um what was the guy's name again oh
that's right the protagonist he is
literally this guy right here probably
can't see because his head's in front of
it I'm going to be naming him norm in my
playthrough and because we are doing
persona 5 we've got this but specially
scalped mode on ahead for you righteous
chick beanie bro a suit but yeah so
Xander which is uh nasim name by the way
oh thank you I'm a long line of super
villains that's excellent
that's know yeah
what made me recognize your voice from
well uh you might recognize me from such
performances as I was the announcer in
super smash brothers for well latest one
play The Ultimate Warrior and camp WTF
WWE bet oh my god what more is the best
yeah he's so much fun so you are helped
literally helming persona 5 as the
protagonist down how does that kind of
feel um it kind of cycles between really
excited because I or I lost way more
hours than I'm willing to admit on that
game uh see I put in 88 myself yeah I'm
the first player boom yeah say and then
it kind of cycles from excitement to
terrified - back to excitement - back to
terrified - oh hey I've got a poop I'm
gonna do that I'm terrified now still
pooping yeah
that's how guys do your poops for the
best beer poops are the best proofs it's
true so you are the protagonist and yeah
that's gonna for I'd put any other
persona games I have it well I played a
Shinigami 10 sake
for last Christmas I bought my brothers
copy and I have kind of an acquaintance
with the Shinigami franchise and the
spin-offs but now I haven't actually
gotten to play persona 3 2 or 1 because
we're going that's look good I guess um
I've seen a few of the persona 3 movies
but that's about it yeah
persona 4 was just like my jam that's
where I came in so for norm I mean the
great thing about him is like he is very
quiet and reserved when he is kind of in
public and in his civvies I guess but
then when he's the Phantom thief he
definitely opens up a lot more he's got
a little bit of a cockiness to him he's
got kind of an edge and like you can see
in the trailers and stuff like he's got
a little bit of that
edge your sort of thing going on which I
really like I enjoy getting to have more
fun of it than just like I am here to
stop the available bad guy person well
if you come from a long line of
supervillain so that it's true yeah yeah
how the hell do you pronounce it or
something okay
I've always said it our sinning okay but
I could be totally wrong and I'm sure
somebody in French is like uh-huh have
pumped him into trap
we apologize France I love you France it
you know a fun more about the denied
because we haven't seen it play it burn
it anything so you're like I guess I
have the power if you do X don't move -
boy that I mean okay fine it's gonna be
crazy but you guys are just gonna have
to wait until if it were protein from
the game releases where might we find
you on the interwebs should be
enterprise in young at this thing with
it stop using anything you do you can
find me on Facebook ed I think it's just
and remotest voiceover and then on
Twitter at Sandra Mel this video because
I'm creative awesome thanks dude thank
you
Oh